[Musique]
une entrée dans le monde des playmobil
pour expliquer l'histoire aux enfants
l'espace richaud a donné carte blanche à
deux artistes et leurs petites figurines
l'un d'entre eux est venue avec ses
trois camions remplis 30 mètres cubes de
playmobil dont il doit y avoir 12 scènes
plus sont grosses scènes centrales et
offrant à mesure on passe d'après
histoire aux romains et gaulois au
moyen-âge
voilà louis xiv les pirates somaliens
petit peu tôt jusqu'à l'époque actuelle
jusqu'à l'espace des reconstitutions de
scènes appelé diorama mais aussi des
photos qui rappellent des tableaux
célèbres
j'ai trouvé dans le playmobil le casting
idéal pour moi pour pouvoir raconter des
choses en fait sérieuse mais aux enfants
des enfants qui ne s'y trompa et
interprète facilement les scènes
représentées faire la bataille avec les
gaulois sont les gaulois soeur le sas
non on a vu des arènes et b la mode des
serpents et des tigres à dents fabre des
bonnes âmes
mais bouge jamais tu organises n'est pas
touché elvis presley les beatles le
cirque l'histoire culturelle est aussi
largement présente
c'est impressionnant il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de nos mobiles puisque dans ta
chambre
et ça prend 10 est assez chouette chacun
peut donc y retrouver son histoire nous
à la rédaction nous avons identifié
notre figurines